well the leadership of mainland China of
course lied about this fires from the
beginning they virtually guaranteed it
would spread across the world and
devastate the global economy all of
which happened will they pay any price
for that Eric Schmidt is the Attorney
General of the state of Missouri today
he made Missouri the first state to sue
China over the Wuhan coronavirus he
joins us Simon general thanks so much
for coming on tonight tell us about this
suit that you have filed well look the
what's become clear in recent weeks as
the the deception the misrepresentation
the concealment of the Chinese
government of the origins of this
vicious virus that's impacted the entire
globe I mean no part of the world has
been spared from the corona virus and
the fact is the Chinese government
misrepresented they were aware of the
human human contact and transmission
very early on
hit that punished and concealed the
evidence from whistleblowers and the
impact has been devastating you had loss
of life here in Missouri you know over
6,000 nearly 6,000 cases nearly 200
deaths people not being allowed to see
folks in nursing homes or funerals the
economic impact the disruption people
living paycheck-to-paycheck who've lost
their jobs it's enormous and our state
legislature goes in next week like a lot
of states to try to craft a state budget
under these circumstances so I felt was
incumbent upon me as the state's chief
legal officer to take that case and to
prosecute that case to the Chinese
government they're responsible for this
and the responsibility lies directly at
their feet have you had any pushback or
disagreement on this yes you know we
feel very confident in the case and
essentially we've we've brought forth
claims of a public nuisance and
negligence the hoarding of PPE is
certainly also one of our allegations
and some folks have an issue as to the
federal Sovereign Immunities Act but
there are exceptions
there are as exceptions for commercial
activity and the fact that they were
running the virality lab the fact that
they were running hospital systems the
fact that they were hoarding PPE we
think fits squarely into that exception
which is why we brought the case sure I
mean other countries have been sued
successfully Iran for example
and really quickly when will you find
out if this case goes forward we filed
it today in the Eastern District in
federal court and we look forward to the
Chinese government's response I mean
this to ultimately is about holding
those responsible for this worldwide
pandemic holding them accountable and we
look forward to them answering the
complaint it's been very specific in our
complaint the factual allegations as far
as the timeline and the
misrepresentations and also our legal
claims we fail are very merited well
there are a lot of specifics out there
terney gentle Schmidt thanks so much for
telling us about it tonight appreciate
it